in the opening scene we are introduced
to a guy named Frank Walker Who records
a message addressing an unseen audience
about the future he states that the
future can be scary and that with each
passing moment they are drawing closer
to the end of the world he recalls his
childhood days when he thought of the
future as an optimistic place the film
then takes us back to 1964 when a young
Frank visits the New York World's Fair
carrying a large bag inside the hall of
inventions he meets a renowned inventor
and competition judge named David Nix
Frank eagerly presents his self-made jet
pack to him explaining to him its
features right here's the Virgin forever
button just then a girl named Athena
shows up and she seems to be impressed
by Frank's invention and his Spirit he
might even have to remove that button
regardless David doesn't show much
enthusiasm for the device and rejects it
as it doesn't work properly feeling
dejected Frank sits outside the where he
is approached by Athena she hands him an
orange lapel pin with a blue T embossed
on it and then asks him to follow her
behind a small group including David
putting on the pin Frank follows the
group to the It's a Small World
attraction where Frank bypasses the line
and Boards one of the boats by himself
when the boat enters a tunnel a laser
scans the pin on his shirt before taking
him through an underground passageway
the boat then stops at a small transport
station that appears to be an elevator
it takes him to a foggy platform where
he notices Athena waving at him from a
flying pod as Frank attempts to follow
robots push him causing him to fall onto
a lower platform soon after a
construction robot appears and
successfully repairs Frank's
malfunctioning jetpack before giving him
a thumbs up however Frank's respite is
short-lived as guards arrive to
apprehend him in a state of panic he
slips and Falls fortunately he has his
jet pack with him that prevents him from
hitting the ground he then flies and
explores the city getting a brief look
at the futuristic world after a while
Frank eventually spots Athena and David
and lands in front of them David still
somehow remains unimpressed and walks
away with a mild expression however
Athena takes Frank's hand and introduces
him to Paradise Tomorrowland in 2015 we
are introduced to a young girl named
Casey who sneaks into the NASA
demolition site located in Florida she
uses a drone to hack the security
cameras and then disrupts all the
Machinery that's intended for the site's
demolition she does this because she
doesn't want her dad who works as a NASA
engineer to lose his job but unbeknownst
to Casey her actions are watched by
Athena when Casey returns home Athena
tells her and discreetly collects a
strand of her hair from her bike helmet
Athena takes out a compact scanner to
extract Casey's DNA and encodes it into
her last Tomorrowland pin the following
day Casey father who is aware of her
actions tells her to stop trying because
the demolition is inevitable
nevertheless Casey persists believing
that her actions no matter how small
contribute to at least slowing down the
process she also reminds him that
keeping up hope is more important later
that evening Casey makes another attempt
to sabotage the demolition but this time
she's caught red-handed by the police
sometime later Casey's father bails her
out and she goes to collect her stuff
during this she spots a t-pin which upon
touching it experiences a sudden vision
of a different place the pin Falls and
when Casey touches it again the same
phenomenon recurs on the third attempt
she finds herself looking at a
futuristic city from a distance Casey
tries to walk towards it only to bump
her head onto the station's wall on
their way back home she shows the PIN to
her father also mentioning that it's
magic but nothing happens when Eddie
touches it probably because he's a
boomer and doesn't believe and he takes
the pin away from Casey the same night
Casey sneaks into her father's room and
reclaims the pen she then Ventures to an
expansive field when she touches the pin
this time she finds herself at the heart
of an awe-inspiring futuristic city with
jet packs and flying trains she
excitedly walks around and also boards a
train to explore the city upon getting
off she notices a group of astronauts
preparing for a space Expedition one of
them invites Casey to join them but at
the same time the pin's temporary magic
expires as a result she's sent back into
reality where she is walking into a
waste deep lake after this Casey
hasten's back home and asks her younger
brother Nate to help her in accessing
their father's computer together they
search for the pin online and eventually
discover an address related to its
Origins Casey decides to visit this
store and asks Nate to cover for her if
their father asks the next morning
Athena arrives at Casey's residence and
asks Nate about about her whereabouts
the latter gives her the camping excuse
but Athena can easily sense his lie and
demands the truth meanwhile Casey
arrives at a store and meets with the
owners named Ursula and Hugo they
disclose to her that the pin serves as
an access key to Tomorrowland a creation
of some of History's Greatest Geniuses
called plus Ultra what so that's a my
hero rip-off young midoriya I am very
disappointed they then press Casey for
information regarding who gave the PIN
to her but she is genuinely unaware
believing that she's lying the owners
press a button to lock the exit door and
take out a pair of futuristic weapons to
kill Casey but fortunately just before
they pull the trigger Athena bursts onto
the scene using a time bomb to freeze
Ursula and Hugo within a force field
Athena and Casey try to run away but the
force field then collapses prompting the
owners to open fire on them in
retaliation Athena engages in a fierce
fight against the tale and eventually
manages to subdue them Athena and Casey
Escape just in time as the store owners
who turn out to be robots
self-destruct no wonder they ripped off
my hero AI can't come up with anything
original following this Athena steals a
random car allowing the two to flee the
scene on their way Athena admits that
she was the one who placed the t-pin in
Casey's bag moreover she reveals herself
to be a robot who is assigned to find
and recruit people who fit the ideals of
Tomorrowland confused and scared Casey
pulls the emergency brake and runs out
of the car Athena chases her only to be
hit by another car the driver comes out
to check on Athena in case he takes this
opportunity to steal the car to drive
away however Athena quickly recovers and
catches up to her in no time she claims
that Casey is Her Last Hope and that
they need to quickly go to Tomorrowland
because they built something they
shouldn't have and after a small
discussion Casey realizes that Athena
won't harm her so she agrees to go with
her the latter then drops her off
outside Frank's house in Pittsfield and
leaves turns out that Frank is the only
one who can lead them to Tomorrowland
left with no choice Casey approaches the
house only to be chased by a guard dog
she trips and falls into the mud which
makes her realize that the dog is not
leaving any Footprints it's merely a
holographic projection disregarding the
illusionary dog she proceeds to knock on
the door she also shows her t-pin on the
camera asking him to take her to
Tomorrowland however she suddenly pushed
away by a blast of air following this
Frank walks out to tell her to go away
as he asserts that Tomorrowland is no
longer in existence and what she
witnessed earlier was merely a
decades-old advertisement with this
declaration Frank Retreats inside and
locks the door nevertheless Casey
remains Resolute and refuses to leave as
the night falls Casey devises a plan she
sets a snowplow on fire force Frank to
exit the house taking this opportunity
she gains entry and locks Frank outside
while exploring the house she discovers
a variety of futuristic devices one
particular machine plays a recording of
a young Frank who is trying to make
Athena laugh and also trying to make
audiences think he's relevant again in
another room she notices an array of
screens keeping up with the news and a
countdown timer before long Frank enters
the house through a secret entrance and
asks Casey to leave she agrees on the
condition that he answers some of her
questions first Franklin reveals that he
was banished from Tomorrowland by David
for having constructed a machine capable
of predicting the future with absolute
Precision their conversation is abruptly
interrupted by the arrival of a group of
robots led by Dave who are there to
capture Casey luckily Frank appears to
be prepared as he already has a lot of
traps in the house he leads Casey
towards the bathroom eliminating all the
robots on their way they then hop into a
bathtub which turns into an escape pod
it soon takes off and lands in a nearby
lake just as the house erupts in Flames
after swimming to the surface Athena
arrives to pick them up and the trio
drive away on Route tensions flare
between Frank and Athena with Frank
still not happy to see her back he
believes that Athena puts up fake
emotions to lure the people and then
abandons them later Athena however
disregards his accusations and continues
driving they soon arrive at a local
station where Frank has installed his
teleportation device although hesitant
at first he eventually agrees to
initiate the process he covers Casey's
eyes and ears with a black sheet as a
part of the teleportation process in a
matter of moments the three of them are
transported to their new location Atop
The Eiffel Tower after subduing a guard
the group proceeds into a small room
adorned with mannequins of historical
figures such as Thomas Edison Gustav
iPhone Jules Verne Mr Beast and Nikola
Tesla Frank claims that the Eiffel Tower
serves as an antenna and a secret
gateway to reach Tomorrowland he then
reveals an Edison tube explaining that
when it is played on a phonograph it
opens a secret entrance when he actually
plays it the tower splits into two parts
and a rocket ship emerges from beneath
just then they noticed Dave and his
agents approaching them so the trio
quickly gets on the rocket and takes off
before the robots can get them after
escaping Earth's gravitational pull the
rocket flips around and goes back
towards Earth breaking through into
another dimension another dimension now
they're ripping off Dragon Ball shortly
after they touch down in Tomorrowland
which now appears to be desolate and
deserted as some Vehicles approach them
Frank hands Athena a bomb which she
hides inside her body David who is now a
city Governor steps out from one of the
vehicles Frank introduces Casey and
asserts that she can fix the flaws in
the future predicting machine hearing
this David decides to take them to a
tachyon machine invented by Frank when
they take the elevator Casey sees
holographic projections which are
flashes of the future upon arriving
Frank instructs Casey on how to operate
the machine allowing her to travel to
any point in time she then sets the
device into the future which shows the
NASA platform is being destroyed
following this Casey travels all around
the world and sees riots and natural
disasters indicating that the world is
ending but despite this Grim Outlook she
refuses to accept it this attitude of
hers causes the future to alter
temporarily Frank eagerly presents this
as evidence of change to David but
instead of being happy the latter knocks
him out with a device in the next scene
Frank regains Consciousness within a
confined room with Athena and Casey
nearby just then Casey realizes that the
machine doesn't show events that will
happen but that could happen she then
suggests turning the machine off so that
it won't share false hope with other
people however David has already decided
to banish them to the real world via a
portal Frank and Casey attempt to convey
their Discovery to David but the latter
refuses to turn off the machine David
admits that he tried to avert a future
apocalypse by warning people but they
instead accepted the end of War as
inevitable refusing to act to make a
better future for their world believing
that Humanity simply gave up David now
intends to allow the apocalypse to
happen so that he can rebuild the world
to his liking when David refuses to
comply Frank activates the elevator via
the controls on David's watch as the two
struggle Frank asks the girls to blow up
the machine Casey grabs the bomb from
Athena and manages to climb into an
elevator while Athena engages in a
fierce battle against two huge robots
unfortunately Casey is unable to throw
the bomb as David controls the elevator
and brings it down since the bomb can't
be deactivated Casey hurls it through
the portal instead the ensuing explosion
causes the building's structure to
collapse trapping David under debris and
pinning his leg moments later Athena
sees a vision of the future where Frank
is shot by David as a result she jumps
in the way and sacrifices herself to
save David in the aftermath Frank
attempts to bring Athena to a repair
station but she tells him that she
cannot be repaired why she's a robot in
her final moments she presents him with
a recording from the past showing how
Frank used to have a crush on her
unaware of the fact that she was a robot
although she was unable to feel his love
he made her feel things that robots
shouldn't that makes no sense Frank gets
emotional realizing that Athena always
believed in him even when others didn't
after making peace with Frank Athena
asks him to use her self-destruct
sequence to destroy the machine with
limited time Frank uses his jet pack to
fly up and drops Athena inside the
machine ultimately destroying the entire
system David is also killed in the
Carnage following this Casey returns
home through the portal and reunites
with her family traumatized forever
collaborating with her family and Frank
she decides to shape the world into a
better place together they construct a
new generation of robots akin to Athena
and produce numerous additional t-pins
they hand over the pins to those robots
and dispatch them all over the world in
order to recruit new dreamers and
thinkers for Tomorrowland subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching